à contre notre profession notre groupe
par le biais de fausses informations
énoncées par des associations radicales
notamment les propos de représentants de
l'association abolitionniste et relayée
sans aucun recul aucune vérification par
la presse pourrait à terme être en
danger les seules entités capables
aujourd'hui de proposer des contenus
adultes réalisant cadre sécurisé et
transparent professionnels il faut donc
parvenir à trouver un équilibre et vous
pouvez mesdames les sénatrices compter
sur l'implication du groupe ares qui se
tirent un père mon intermédiaire à votre
disposition pour tenter de répondre à
toutes vos questions
[Musique]